[Music]
at the annual Athenian drama festival in
426 bc a comic play called the
babylonians written by a young poet
named Aristophanes was awarded first
prize but the play's depiction of athens
conduct during the Peloponnesian War was
so controversial that afterwards a
politician named Cleon took Aristophanes
to court for slandering the people of
Athens in the presence of foreigners
Aristophanes struck back two years later
with a play called the Knights in it he
openly mocked Cleon ending with cleon's
character working as a lowly sausage
seller outside the city gates
this style of satire was a consequence
of the unrestricted democracy of 5th
century Athens and is now called old
comedy Aristophanes plays the world's
earliest surviving comic dramas a
stuffed full of parodies songs sexual
jokes and surreal fantasy they often use
wild situations like a hero flying to
heaven on a dung beetle or a net cast
over a house to keep the owners father
trapped inside in order to subvert
audience expectations and they've shaped
how comedies been written and performed
ever since the word comedy comes from
the ancient Greek Comus revel and Lloyd
singing and it differed from his
companion art form tragedy in many ways
where ancient Athenian tragedies dealt
with the downfall of the high and mighty
their comedies usually ended happily and
where tragedy almost always borrowed
stories from legend comedy addressed
current events Aristophanes comedies
celebrated ordinary people and attacked
for powerful his targets were arrogant
politicians war mongering generals and
self-important intellectuals exactly the
people who sat in the front row of the
theater where everyone could see their
reactions as a result they were referred
to as Como doom annoy those made fun of
in
Aristophanes vicious and often obscene
mockery held these leaders to account
testing their commitment to the city one
issue in particular inspired much of
Aristophanes work for Filipinos Ian's
war between Athens and Sparta in peace
written in 421 BC a middle-aged Athenian
freeze the embodiment of peace from a
cave where she'd been exiled by
profiteering politicians then in the
aftermath of a crushing naval defeat for
Athens in 411 BC Aristophanes wrote
Lysistrata in this play
the women of Athens grow sick of war and
go on a sex strike until their husbands
make peace other plays use similarly
fantastic scenarios to skewer topical
situations such as ink clouds where
Aristophanes mocked fashionable
philosophical thinking the hero strep
sea ADIZ enrolls in socrates new
philosophical school where he learns how
to prove that wrong is right and that a
debt is not a debt no matter how
outlandish these plays get the heroes
always prevail
in the end Aristophanes also became the
master of the parabolas a comic
technique where actors addressed the
audience directly often praising the
playwright or making topical comments
and jokes for example in birds the
chorus takes the role of different birds
and threatens the Athenian judges that
if their play doesn't win first prize
they'll defecate on them as they walk
around the city perhaps the judges
didn't appreciate the joke as the play
came in second
by exploring new ideas and encouraging
self-criticism in Athenian society
Aristophanes not only mopped his
fellow-citizens
but he shaped the nature of comedy
itself hailed by some scholars as the
father of comedy
his fingerprints are visible upon comic
techniques everywhere from slapstick to
double axe to impersonations
to political satire through the praise
of free speech and the celebration of
ordinary heroes his plays made his
audience think while they laughed and
his retort to Cleon in 425 BC still
resonates today I'm a comedian so I'll
speak about justice no matter how hard
it sounds to your ears did you know that
Ted ed has a student voice program
students between 8 and 18 years old are
invited to develop and share their big
ideas on the ted platform visit ed
ted.com
slash clubs to learn more
[Music]